More than 2,000,000 foreigners are
entered French territory under the Macronie,
is the equivalent of the city of Paris.
That seven hundred thousand and
nine hundred thousand illegal immigrants live on our soil,
it is the equivalent of the population of Marseille
and 95% of the octf are not executed.
Quatre-cent-vingt-trois-mille illegal immigrants benefit
of state medical assistance.
It costs us
1milliard-deux-cents-millions euros per year,
more than 40,000 alleged minors of the company
for 1 average annual cost of €50,000 per minor,
1 cost of2.000.000.000 euros per year per.
On thedeux-millions-six-cent-mille
Algerians living on our soil,
42% are unemployed or inactive,
while benefiting from the range of social wings.
Immigration costs according to the cdf
35 billion euros,
French public finance,
every year.